what's up believe nation I started the
meant to me serious with the goal to try
to learn from people who've done a lot
more than us
hang around them a little bit longer I'm
by being in their environment hopefully
some of their mindsets their beliefs our
way of thinking seep into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to learn from Jim
Carrey on stayin motivated mentor me Jim
and as always guys as you're watching
the clip if you hear something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below and put
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired and also when you write it down
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself to enjoy
you
Oh
silliness had been with Jim Carrey since
he was a baby born with a crooked hat
his faces never failed to get a laugh
but family parties are at school where
he says being the class clown helped him
to make friends but Jim dropped out of
school in grade 9 to mold his act three
years later his first TV appearance the
impressions were there but the nuances
weren't thank you very much
my name is Jimmy Chiara and I am the
president of the United States of
America thank you thank you very much
though the nuances are here now but I
did not come easily so now it used to be
Jim struggles trying to perfect his
impressions usually performed at a
popular comedy club in Toronto that's a
fact I used to drive like 50 miles back
and forth from Jackson's point every
every second night or every every night
to do a set of checkups for free no pay
not even the gas stove or anything
nothing good so I used to do that did
that for the longest time kept working
until people started to take notice you
know and and the rest was history at one
point I'm not at one point as I hear you
still do you would be in front of a
mirror and just make faces always yeah
for me it was it was so much fun to me
to sit in my room and make faces and
talk to myself in different voices and
things and I go it looks like family
there it is what sound you know yeah he
does that you know like I just sit for
hours doing that and and my parents were
so worried they would you know they
would say you know my mother tried to
scare me with the spiritual thing you
know it's just like it cannot stop doing
that you're going to see the devil and
that kind of thing and and I of course
that you know that just made me do it
more I mean I got a lot of support from
my parents that's the one thing that I
always appreciated is that they didn't
tell me I was being stupid they told me
I was being funny
that was a difference when you were 15
your father took you to a comedy club to
perform yeah my mother dresses me in a
polyester suit tells me you know this is
what all the boys are wearing ah and
sends me down there my father helped me
write my act and and I I went down to
the comedy club and the owner of the
club had this little thing that he liked
to do where he would stand backstage
with a microphone and all kinds of fun
effects and you know heckle new
comedians and so when I got up there it
was just horrendous he was like
backstage going totally totally boring
they were playing you know excerpts from
Jesus Christ Superstar like you know
crucify him crucify him crucify that
kind of thing so you know when you go
through a few of those experiences you
kind of develop a thick skin when it
comes to being ridiculed or whatever why
didn't you give it up I couldn't I I
mean I don't have a trait this is my
spot where the universe where I hang out
with the Buddha and Krishna and you know
all those guys are you geezers
I'm a Buddhist I'm a Muslim I'm a
Christian I'm whatever you want me to be
you know it all comes down to the same
thing you're in a loving place or you're
in an unloving place if you're with me
right now
we cannot be unhappy is there a positive
there possible just try his faith is
personal and mystical he believes that
miracles will come true if you just
believe in them and he has his life and
his career to prove it but he does think
that people who express strong feelings
about spirituality run the risk of being
labeled a kook you know what the hell
what the hell you know whatever I just
want to be myself by wounds a few French
people who
with the fact that thank you know that
there's other forces in the world that's
okay with me when I was a kid
I brought relief to my family by taking
their painful concerns and alkalizing
them into comedy and they enjoyed
watching me play most of the time later
my career in show business blossomed
after I made the conscious decision to
serve the audience what I thought they
really needed to see someone who's
carefree in the world and treats it all
with a healthy dose of irreverence yes
that's how I meant to say it since very
early in my memory the real thrill in my
life wasn't personal recognition as much
as knowing that I could affect people in
a positive way and have fun doing it
before I had money I used to write have
a nice day on $20 bills and leave them
where I knew people in need would find
them I didn't wait around to see their
smiles I just was satisfied knowing that
for one brief moment I might feel a
little bit lucky as time passed my
interest in people's welfare has grown
but for me living in this world will
always be a game the object of which is
to create as much goodwill as possible I
realize now more than ever that the most
valuable commodity in life is the
feeling you get when you give compassion
is the currency that leads to true
wealth I created better use so I could
continue to expand my awareness of what
people need to relieve or prevent
suffering wherever possible and to offer
a kind of assistance that allows people
to grow towards independence and
self-actualization and a healthy dose of
reverence
a better you means a better universe
anything that doesn't work out and you
show that I might not get any any show
that I might do that doesn't turn out
well gets pulled off or something like
that I always think of as this is the
way it was supposed to be that's the way
it was supposed to happen because
there's something bigger down the road
there's something better down the road
and that and this is happening because
I'm not ready or you know and it's
always happened that way I mean the
first time I ever went to Yuk Yuk's when
I was 15 years old I went to Church
Street the old Jack's was two lanes of a
bowling alley and I went there and and I
was not good it was all right I mean I
was you were 15 I was 15 I had a white
polyester suit on my mum put on which I
went down there with that and got up on
stage and and I was doing all right
really but the owner of the club got on
the mic backstage and started going
totally boring and all of a sudden it
wasn't hip enough for them so so I was
pretty shattered and I didn't go back
for two years and then my father said
when I was 17 I started doing little
shows here and there again and he said
why don't you go back to your kicks I
said no way I want to go back there and
he said well you really you know you
should get over it I mean if you if
you're going to going to go into the
business and you want to do it seriously
you can't have those barriers you know
and I went back and I did great and I
what became a regular and a headliner
and and it built from there and then
when I went down to Los Angeles the same
thing happened I went to the comedy star
I did all right but not good enough to
become a regular and I become totally
discouraged the comedy star I came back
to Toronto like everybody doesn't do
well down there comes back on hate Los
Angeles it's such a crummy place oh
really you can't raise kids there and
all that stuff in the comedy stores rat
race it's a robbery but then two years
later again my father he says to me well
you should try and get into the comedy
store
and my manager set up a showcase there I
went in and I did well it became a
regular there and everything has
happened from there since it's just it's
been incredible and it always goes in
stages like that so I accept the fact
that I fail you know because I know that
it's that's the way it's supposed to be
no education hey I had no high school
diploma I didn't even have a GED I quit
high school halfway through grade 10 I
didn't have a lot of options I would be
a dishwasher or waiter
custodial work of some sort so I decided
I might as well go and do something
creative I decided to go to the comedy
sort of laughs acting The Improv you
know all all of those clubs every night
and make my twenty five bucks a pop a
set is my version of
being a waiter we would compromise I
decided to make out of that came in
living color and out of that came
touring
auditoriums 5,000 Cedars is a really
creative time
I was able to prove that I didn't have
to be an impressionist that I had a
personality of my own and however
abrasive it might be from time to time a
long story short all of it came from
that compromise from that deciding to do
what I didn't want to do things you
can't do
or the things you're not allowed to do
maybe the executives coming says you
can't do that whatever it is it's too
expensive you get angry to get out of
your mind about it because you've been
cleaning too this concept in this image
that you have of how it should be done
and invariably most times after that
storm is passed and you actually sit
down and go okay we can't do it that way
how can we do it you end up with
something even better than what was
there before and you go
universe that's how it works like
relationships everything the thing that
has taken away if you're clinging to if
you're trying to fix and you're trying
to secure it make sure it doesn't go
away we think your life will be
destroyed everything will be ruined and
it's just universe goings no I have
something better just have some faith
sometimes compromise is actually the way
to get to what you want doing what you
don't want is the way to what you do
want
medication I would never have made that
going back and what I did
damn I wanted to ask you some years ago
you wrote yourself a check yes I did I
guess it's like six seven years ago now
I wrote a check out to myself for ten
million dollars for acting services
rendered and in nineteen by Thanksgiving
1995 and I put it in my wallet and I
carried it for that many years and and
what happened was basically a few months
ago we did the deal for them and asked
for ten million dollars ten million
dollars payment for doing the math right
payment for doing the mask too and and
so it's very surreal for me it's it's
it's strange and I used to go up to
Mulholland Drive every night sit on the
side of the road look out at the lights
and and go you know unpopular actor I'm
you know every every director wants to
work with me and I used to like open my
arms and imagine things you know things
that I wanted to come in my way and
stuff and and what I would do it was a
way of dealing with you know being
completely out of work I would stay up
there until I actually believed that I
had all these things and then I would
drive down the mountain feeling like the
biggest star in Hollywood like I was
working all the time like like the best
people wanted to work with me and I had
my thing in my pocket my little check in
my pocket you know it's our intention
our intention is everything nothing
happens on this planet without it not
one single thing has ever been
accomplished without intention so I
started thinking about my life and I
started thinking about this conference
and what we're about and and I looked
back and I thought well I was two people
my whole life I was in the living room
entertaining people being a monkey we
you know doing my thing for the company
and
and trying to relieve my mother who was
suffering she had rheumatoid arthritis
and lightest and everything everything
under the Sun that was nagging at her
and she was depressed and I wanted her
to be free and I wanted her to realize
that her life was worth something
because she gave birth to someone who
was worth something
and then I would go into my room and I
would sit with the legal pad I was a
little kid I would sit there and I would
try to figure out what it meant what I
was all about why are we here what is
this and one day I read something from
Buddha that said that all spirituality
is about relieving suffering and I
suddenly realized that's what I'm doing
in the other room and and I'm aligned
you know this my purpose is aligned with
this so I felt incredibly lucky I lose
sight of that all the time I get caught
up in different concerns and ego
concerns but I'm so lucky to be a part
of this community and to to do something
that is a value and I really cherished
that and we are all one thing it really
is true now fear is going to be a player
in your life but you get to decide how
much you can spend your whole life
imagining ghosts worrying about the
pathway to the future but all there will
ever be is what's happening here in the
decisions we make in this moment which
are based in either love or fear so many
of us choose our path out of fear
disguised as practicality
[Music]
what we really want seems impossibly out
of reach and ridiculous to expect so we
never dare to ask the universe for it
I'm saying I'm the proof that you can
ask the universe for it my father could
have been a great comedian but he didn't
believe that that was possible for him
and so he made a conservative choice
instead he got a safe job as an
accountant and when I was 12 years old
he was let go from that safe job and our
family had to do whatever we could to
survive I learned many great lessons
from my father not the least of which
was that you can fail at what you don't
want so you might as well take a chance
on doing what you love so thank you guys
so much for watching I'd love to know
what did you learn from this video what
cliff spoke to you the most and what
you're going to take from these clips
and immediately apply to your life or to
your business somehow leave it down in
the comments below I'm super curious to
find out finally you want to give a
quick shudder to insight junkie thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and making that
awesome YouTube video on it as well I'm
really really glad that you enjoyed the
book and I appreciate your support if
you knew how to start your business or
how to make more money this book may
just be the answer that you're looking
for today we're talking about your one
word by Evan Carmichael so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon